my name is Glen cats I'm a lecturer in
the Department of Civil Engineering and
my project was to convert three classes
that I've been teaching in the
department of civil engineering into an
online form that would then be available
for students to take at anytime through
the year and kind of at their own pace
the teaching and with technology
workshop really got me thinking pretty
differently about how to use online
learning and really what some of the
possibilities and the advantages of
working with the technology are so at
the beginning yeah thinking about moving
to the online technology it was all
about inefficiency oh we could somehow
deliver the content in a way that makes
it easier to get a accessible at
different times very easy to repeat
things like that okay but in thinking
about the lessons that came out of the
workshop it really became much more
about trying to use the technology to
create just room or kind of a better
learning experience that really
ultimately shifting my thinking from
thinking about the class as a what
information delivery exercise to really
more of can I support and encourage a
culture of behaviors that leave to a
kind of a lifelong learning experience
where II you understand how you go out
and get materials you interact with
others you combine those together and
ultimately make it your own you're
responsible for your own learning
experience yeah I think we got to a
really great outcome and something that
uses the tools you know kind of
creatively but I'm also very keen to see
what happens in the first release I'm
certain that the first set of students
that take it this way we're gonna have
some great feedback and we'll learn a
lot just being able to work with the
instructional designers on the team has
been incredibly helpful because they've
given me new ways of thinking about what
I'm doing sort of new tools and
frameworks that help me understand
myself and what's going on in the
classroom which is then empowering me to
kind of make a change that was sort of a
huge shift and I owe that very directly
to the help of my instructional
designers so it's been a fantastic
experience